-It is time for
"Tonight Show Summer Reads."
Here we go.
-♪ "Summer Reads" ♪
♪ "Tonight Show Summer Reads" ♪
-Now, this is our annual
"Tonight Show" Book Club,
where we have six books.
I have not read
any of these books.
-Really?
-We do book clubs differently
on our show, but yeah.
Eventually,
I'll read one of them, yeah.
We do love books here
on the show.
But, anyways,
these are all fantastic books.
What we -- Six of these books --
I want you to vote.
If you go to our website,
tonightshow.com,
you'll see how to vote.
You get one vote,
so make it count.
And then, on Monday --
Voting ends Sunday night,
so Monday,
we'll decide which one
we're all going to
read together.
-Aww.
-Yeah.
And then we'll read books.
We'll talk about it.
It's like a summer read.
-Yeah.
-This is what you need.
Yeah. So, here we go.
Here's the books.
I'll go through the plots fast.
Emily Henry,
"People We Meet on Vacation."
Basically, a guy and girl go on
vacation together for years.
Then they have a fallout.
They don't go one year.
Then they decide to go back and
go on vacation and just, like,
fix the problems they have.
But they ask the question,
can men and women
actually be "just friends"?
-Ooh!
Ooh!
-What?!
-Snap!
-"Razorblade Tears."
Yeah, this is by S.A. Cosby.
His last novel won
an "L.A. Times" book award
for Best Mystery.
He knows how to do it.
Basically, these two ex-cons --
their sons are murdered,
but the local cops
won't do anything about it.
So they take matters
into their own hands.
There's twists.
There's turns.
"One Last Stop."
This is a, like,
a magic type of romance book.
"New York Times"
best-selling author.
A girl gives up on love.
She's like, "Eh, forget it."
She's in New York.
Goes on the subway and meets
this beautiful girl,
and they fall in love,
but the girl is trapped in
1970-something.
-Ooh!
-It's a time thing.
Yeah, it's awesome.
Will she find love?
Will she get to her stop?
I don't know.
-Just one last one.
-This is "Crying in H Mart,"
Michelle Zauner.
[ Crowd cheers ]
I know -- I love H Mart.
And -- But you know her as
Japanese Breakfast.
This is Japanese Breakfast.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So this is a memoir.
And it's beautiful.
It's about growing up
Asian-American
in the United States.
And her mom would always teach
her about Korean culture.
And then,
after her mom passes away,
how the things
her mom taught her
helped her shape
who she is today.
-Aww.
-It's cool.
This is "The Final Revival
of Opal & Nev,"
by Dawnie Walton.
Debut novel.
Debut author here, so if you
want to support a debut author.
"New York Times" calls it
"A packed time capsule that
doubles as a stick of dynamite."
-Whoa! Don't let that blow up.
-I didn't even have to tell you
what the story is about.
-Yeah.
-But it's a group from
the '70s that want to reunite,
but then some
dark secret comes up,
and they're like,
"Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa."
Then this one here, "The Plot."
This is by Jean Hanff Korelitz.
This is the author of the book
that "The Undoing" was based on.
-Ooh!
-Yeah, it's the new book.
And here's the plot of
"The Plot."
An English teacher is teaching
a class on how to write a book.
One student has a good story,
but the student dies.
-Ooh!
-So what does the teacher do?
Takes the story.
-Ooh!
-And he becomes the
famous author from the story.
Until one day,
he gets an e-mail.
Guess what the subject says.
-Say what?
-"You are a thief."
-Ooh!
Dang!
-So, what I was thinking was --
-Plot of "The Plot."
Real quick, so before -- 'Cause
you got to get your votes in.
These are all winners,
to be honest,
so support all of them.
Go to your local bookstore,
get all of them, if you want.
That's really all we care about.
We want everyone to win here.
But I want one to be chosen
by Sunday night
so we can all read it together.
I thought it would be fun --
Do we have time?
Can I read the first line
from every book?
What if I just read
the first line?
You judge
the book not by the cover.
-No, 'cause no one
would do that.
Judge it by the first line.
-If you're going by the cover,
which one would you go with?
"One Last Stop"?
Oh, "H Mart" -- I like this one.
-Yeah.
-Alright, so, here we go.
Which one?
In no order,
'cause they're all good.
-That one.
-Which one?
-That one in your hand.
Yeah. No.
-I'm gonna do
"Razorblade tears."
-First line of
"Razorblade Tears."
-First line.
"Ike tried to remember a time
when men with badges
coming to his door
early in the morning
brought anything other than
heartache and misery,
but try as he might,
nothing came to mind."
-Ooh! Ex-con.
"One Last Stop" -- first line.
-First line is,
"Can I touch you?"
-Ooh!
Oh, hot! Steamy!
♪♪
Spicy!
Spicy, steamy!
Wow! You had to Purell that.
-I got to Purell that guy.
Alright, that's good.
That's steamy already.
-Wow.
-That steamed me up
a little bit.
-Wow.
-"People We Meet on Vacation."
Here we go.
-Love it.
-First line. First line.
"On vacation,
you can be anyone you want."
-Ooh!
-Bit of a thinker.
-"Crying in H Mart."
-Here we go.
-I think this is gonna be...
Oof!
"Ever since my mom died,
I cry in H Mart."
-Aww!
-I knew -- Why would I -- I knew
that was gonna make me sad.
-It's sad.
-That's great.
I'm crying already, yeah.
Alright, "Opal & Nev."
"Disclosure -- my father,
a drummer named Jimmy Curtis,
fell in love with Opal Jewel
in the summer of 1970."
-Hmm.
-Okay.
"The Plot."
-You're not gonna give us
the plot.
You're just giving
the first line of "The Plot."
-"Jacob Finch Bonner,
the once-promising author
of the 'New & Noteworthy'
(New York Times Book Review)
novel 'The Invention of Wonder,'
let himself into the office
he'd been assigned
on the second floor of
Richard Peng Hall,
set up his beat-up leather
satchel on the barren desk,
and looked around in
something akin to despair."
-Mm!
-There you go.
Those are the first lines,
right there, of each book.
You guys, which one are
you going to do?
Which one are you
gonna vote for?
There's our books right there.
There's our books.
Go to
tonightshow.com/summerreads
to cast your vote.
Voting ends Sunday night,
and we'll announce the winner
on Monday's show.